las conclusiones de la reunión entre
Anthony blinken y Benjamín netañaju no
se salieron de la norma ambos
coincidieron en la fortaleza de la
alianza entre Estados Unidos e Israel la
importancia de ampliar Los acuerdos de
Israel con naciones Árabes y por
supuesto evitar que Irán desarrolle
armas nucleares de ahí por ejemplo que
la semana pasada las fuerzas armadas de
ambos estados hayan realizado un gran
ejercicio militar conjunto Aunque este
cuarto viaje de blinken a la región
llevaba en la agenda larga Data ocurre
en unos días de Gran violencia tras la
redada israelí que mató a diez
palestinos y el ataque a la salida de
una sinagoga que dejó siete israelíes
Muertos pero el secretario de estado
apeló a lo habitual condolencias solo
para las víctimas israelíes el llamado a
una desescalada ya no alejarse de una
solución de dos estados apenas Algo más
expresó antes en su aterrizaje en
terabyte cuando también advirtió que no
se tomen acciones vengativas por los
ataques en Jerusalén sin embargo el
gobierno israelí Está avanzando con más
medidas contra los palestinos o
cuestionadas un castigo colectivo y se
han multiplicado las agresiones de
colonos israelíes en sí Jordania ocupada
esto en un enero que es el mes más
mortífero para los palestinos en
cisjordania desde 2015 con 35 muertos
por fuego de las fuerzas israelíes o de
colonos incluidos ocho menores y una
mujer de 60 años por último blinken le
recomendó Vane a que las medidas de su
nueva colección con partidos radicales
de extrema derecha y Ultra religiosos
surjan del consenso y de la defensa de
las instituciones en Clara alusión a su
intento de reformar el sistema judicial
así el secretario de estado en fira el
cierre de su gira por medio oriente cuyo
último capítulo será Este martes en
ramala con una reunión con el presidente
de la autoridad Palestina Paz